hi martin hey valentine i heard you
wrote a web app and would like to run it
in the cloud
yes i want a simple web app also i love
serverless and i need to deploy my app
to the cloud
today we'll explore three different ways
i can make that happen
[Music]
you know i'm a big fan of qr codes they
are one of the most
underrated pieces of brilliant
technology of the last decades
well they're beautiful so what do you
want to do with these things
today i'll show you a nice cloud app
called hotmaze
to transfer a file from my computer to
my mobile phone
for this i could plug a usb cable or
maybe
send myself an email or use a dropbox or
google drive
but i prefer qr codes okay
that sounds neat tell me more i'll make
a very quick demo
here i have a picture of a gopher on my
computer
i drag and drop it here and bam
generating a qr code then i scan
the qr code and then i have the gopher
on my phone
that's it oh cool does it also work with
video files or text files
yes you can send any file you want
okay so this is a cloud service yes
the most simple way to achieve a
transfer between the two devices who
don't know each other very well
is to have the computer upload to the
cloud
and the mobile download from the cloud
okay
so where do you host the web page and
where do you upload the files
i have a strong preference for
serverless because i don't have to
manage
instances myself because of cost
i don't pay when it's not in use and
because of
automatic scaling in case i have
thousands of friends
using the service at the same time to
upload their own gophers
in google cloud i'm spoiled for choices
of serverless compute and hosting
options
okay so which one did you choose all of
them
i mean there are several valid
combinations to choose from
let's explore three possible options
first
app engine standard i've been loving
this one
even before the word serverless existed
see app engine can both host my html and
static resources
and process what happens in the cloud
backend
when i drop a file executing my source
code
first i created a regular go web server
that i tested locally on my workstation
then i could deploy it without modifying
the source code
this is the command line i used to
deploy to app engine
i chose go out of 6 languages available
in app engine standard on file drop
we asked the web app to generate two
secure urls
one to let the browser upload to cloud
storage
and one to let the phone download from
cloud storage
okay but so far the server is only
connected to the web page
in the computer browser how can you push
anything to the phone
you don't even know its ip address
that's the beauty of the qr code
the web page encodes the secure download
url
inside the qr code and this is all the
info that is needed for the phone to
retrieve the file
when scanning the qr code and extracting
the url
amazing so to summarize you did all this
using app engine
and cloud storage yes that was
option number one option number two is
google cloud functions
you see functions are great to quickly
implement something to do in response to
an event
for example our events are someone just
drag and dropped a file
and someone just scanned a url qr code
we also need to host the web page itself
and for this i recommend
firebase hosting i have a command to
deploy
each function and another command to
deploy
the website static sets so
firebase hosting for the front end and
cloud functions for the backend logic
and the cloud storage for the temporary
file
that's right functions are a modern
approach for developing services that
are stateless loosely coupled that
process
incoming events and communicate with
each other by message passing
they are a good fit for fine-grained
micro-services
okay you said you had a third serverless
alternative
yes we can deploy the whole thing
front-end
and back-end to cloudrun for my app it's
very similar to deploying to app engine
but with explicit containers so if you
already have a container-driven workflow
and use a container registry then
deploying to cloud run will be seamless
you can also install almost any binary
dependency in
you need in a container which is
mind-blowing in my opinion
if like me you don't know that much
about docker files and container
technologies though
you may like the ready-to-use build
packs for deployment
okay valentine what's your
recommendation
well the three serverless solutions work
really well
because the app design is stateless and
all these platforms accept
go as a backend language they all
achieve high scalability
and cost efficiency if you want to know
more about the small differences in the
developer experience
and in the infrastructure model
trade-offs please check the articles
linked
in the description so i have hundreds of
photos and videos of cats
on my hard drive could i use your app to
copy them to my phone
photos of cats really yes i guess
you could use my app for that
thank you for watching you can also find
the source code
for this app in the description below
feel free to add any questions you might
have
in the comments